[Music]
Tesla's gonna win level 5 they really
are so let's talk about it you think
you're focused on level 2 currently
currently we're gonna be one to two
years behind Tesla getting to level five
okay we're interested right we're
enjoying it you're in I'm just saying
once Tesla gets it we're one to two
years behind
I'm not making any timeline on when
Tesla's that's right you did that's
brilliant so that what do you think
about this the most level four companies
are kind of just doing their usual
safety driver during full time and kind
of testing and then Tesla does basically
trying to go from lane-keeping to full
autonomy what do you think about that
approach how successful would it be a
ton better approach because Tesla is
gathering data on a scale that none of
them are they're putting real users
behind the behind the wheel the cars
it's I think the only strategy that
works the incremental well so there's a
few components to test approach that's
that's more than just incrementally you
spoke with is the ones the software so
over-the-air software updates necessity
I mean way more ease have those - those
aren't but those differentiate from the
automakers right no link keeping assist
systems have no cars a link keeping
system have that except Tesla yeah and
the other one is the data the other
direction which is the ability to query
the data I don't think they're actually
collecting as much days people think but
the ability to turn on collection and
turn it off
you